[Musique]
ici à verrières pour l'inauguration de
l'extension d'un établissement sur le
québec marie des rosés et françois bock
nous nous sommes beaucoup investis ces
dernières années c'est essentiel du
pouvoir continuer créer des places en
établissement nous avons de plus en plus
de personnes qui ont besoin d'un
accompagnement dans la dépendance et
s'il n'y a plus de créations de places
bien le prix de journée augmentera donc
pouvoir accompagner cette démographie
qui va vers le grand âge évidemment nous
attendons des autorités on y sert de la
santé des agences régionales de santé
qu'il y ait de plus en plus de créations
de places à la fois pour les personnes
âgées et aussi pour les personnes
alitées handicapés nous avons des
établissements du qualité dans le
département ici à verrières en est
l'exemple et donc il faut continuer à
proposer ces services est aussi créateur
évidemment d'emploi dans votre proximité
[Musique]